we're gonna find any of us we'll start
off nice and easy because this is an
example I just gave you the year if you
did notice the public we're gonna give
this a go and I'll show you how to find
him it's really simple what you do is
you start by writing down the values the
coefficients whatever they represent now
this is a matrix what we're gonna do is
we're going to augment it to remember
what augmenting is it's when you put two
matrices you just jam them together so
you can do the same set of operations to
both I'm going to augment it with its
corresponding identity matrix okay so
I'm going to slap it next to this guy
and now this is my automatic matrix now
my goal is I want to do operations to
this thing such that the identity matrix
comes up over here instead of over here
right so I'm going to do operations to
the whole two by four matrix and what I
want to end up with is with one zero
zero one on this side and there's going
to be something else on this side that's
something else that's going to be the
inverse okay okay so let's give this a
go shall we
here's our goal we want to turn this
into one zero zero at once okay there's
an easy first step
think about what would you do you should
take the row in the first row and you
should divide by two that'll make that
one so if that's gonna become a 1 that's
gonna become a zero right but you've got
this row this whole row is being divided
by two so that should become a half okay
and zero my pleasure
okay now even though I could do this
well actually yeah you know what I'm
just gonna do it's two steps because
relatively simple all right now I want
to work on this row so what would you
suggest that I do I should do right to
take away no one and that'll knock out
this bag right so it's gonna become one
- you wrote half zero
let's see you that'll become zero that's
still a four this will become negative
1/2
and 1-0 that's the one okay so far so
good I've only done one elementary row
operation time so hopefully even if you
miss it you can still go back and see
how many making one change I only need
to do one more step right I should
divine so this putz set I now have the
identity matrix there okay that first
row is already done and this should
become okay so what's happened if I call
this guy up here if I call this a what
you ended up with on this side that's
the inverse okay okay and you can test
it out because if I multiply these two
matrices together I ought to come back
to the identity matrix right from here
to here Row 2 minus Row 1 this one is
1/2 and then this one is row 2 divided
by that form let's try it out let's
multiply that let's see what happens I
am now going to multiply a by a inverse
okay so that should be 2014 times okay
all of these awkward fractions they not
so bad as you'll see in a second okay
let's give it a go just like before rows
then columns rows in column watch I'm
gonna do all of the numbers I'm gonna
write them all out I'll show you all the
dot products so you don't lose track
okay Row 2 times 1/2 yep Plus what 0
times negative 1/8
it's that okay whoo how convenient
okay that was one doc right I'll move
over to the right two times zero plus
zero times a quantum very sweet huh move
down a row okay I've got a one in a form
that I'm going to match up to these guys
okay
1 times 1/2 plus 4 times negative na
that's 1/2 that's negative 1/2
whoo last stop right okay same row down
here 1 by 0 4 by 1/4 a snap
it worked in there and that's how you
know whether you've got the inverse or
not